lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
practicar la simplificación de
expresiones y aquí tenemos algunos
números que se ven algo complicados y
como siempre los invito a que pausa en
el vídeo y traten de simplificar esta
expresión por su cuenta antes de que lo
resolvamos aquí bueno suponiendo que
ustedes ya lo intentaron por su cuenta
veamos esto tenemos menos 5.55 menos
8.55 c + 4.35 c lo primero que voy a
hacer es combinar estos términos que
tienen se podemos agregar menos 8.55 c a
4.35 c
y esto es menos 8.55 4.35 solo estoy
sumando los coeficientes de ese y
seguimos teniendo este menos 5.55 aquí
al frente y ponemos nuestro signo de más
aquí como calculamos menos 8.55 más 4.35
hay un par de maneras en la que podemos
visualizar esto una es decir bueno esto
es el negativo de 8.55
- 4.35 y 8.55 4.35 es bueno 8
4 es 4 55 centésimas menos 35 centésimas
son 20 centésimas aquí escribimos 4.20
que es lo mismo que 4.2 y todo esto
podemos reemplazarlo con el menos 4.2
por lo que toda mi expresión se ha
simplificado a menos 5.55 menos 4.2 c y
con eso terminamos ya no podemos
simplificarlo más pues no podemos
agregar este término que no tiene la
variable con este término que sí la
tiene así que esto es lo más sencillo
que podemos llegar
hagamos otro ejemplo
aquí tengo otros números que parecen
complicados expresados en fracciones
tenemos dos quintos de m menos cuatro
quintos menos tres quintos de m cómo
podemos simplificarlo pues puedo sumar
los términos que tienen a m también es
el orden podemos reacomodar esto como
dos quintos de m menos tres quintos de m
menos cuatro quintos lo único que
hicimos fue cambiar el orden y ahora
puedo sumar estos dos términos con m y
tendremos dos quintos menos tres quintos
y todo esto por m
menos cuatro quintos cuánto es dos
quintos menos tres quintos pues va a ser
menos un quinto menos un quinto de m
menos cuatro quintos y nuevamente aquí
terminamos ya no podemos simplificar más
esto no puedo sumar este término que
involucra m con este otro término que no
tiene a la m así que terminamos aquí
hagamos un ejemplo más
este está interesante tenemos paréntesis
y como siempre pausa en el vídeo para
ver si ustedes pueden simplificar esto
vamos a resolverlo juntos y lo primero
que quiero hacer es distribuir este 2
para tener 3 términos que se sumen o se
resten si distribuimos este 2 nos va a
quedar 2 por un quinto de m
son dos quintos de m2 por menos dos
quintos nos va a dar menos cuatro
quintos más tres quintos como podemos
simplificar más esto tenemos estos dos
términos que no involucran a la variable
que son sólo números los podemos sumar
menos cuatro quintos más tres quintos
cuánto es esto pues va a ser menos un
quinto menos un quinto y aquí tenemos
dos quintos de m2 quintos de m menos un
quinto
y con eso terminamos lo hemos
simplificado lo más que hemos podido